[Music]
tensions between Prince Harry megan
morkul and the royal family seemed to be
cooling down et has learned I want you
to hear the truth for me when the couple
made their final appearance with Prince
William and Kate Middleton at the
Commonwealth Day service on March 9th
things were icy
there was a brief hello a nod of
acknowledgement between the four of them
but no moment for them to come together
for a hug or even a conversation so it
did feel that there was quite a lot of
distance between the four of them now
two weeks later a source tells ET that
the Sussex is and the royal family
are in a better space adding that Harry
and Megan are still on track to step
down as senior Royals on March 31st as
planned quote while of course there have
been tensions the family is getting
through it the decision that's I have
made for my wife and I to step back is
not one I made lightly the Sussex duo
announced their decision to step back as
senior Royals in a bombshell statement
in January adding that they were working
to become financially independent and
plan to split their time between the UK
and Canada I hope that helps you
understand what did it come to that I
would step my family back from all I
have ever known
just stickers to take a step forward
into what I hope can be a more peaceful
life our source reiterates that this was
a difficult decision for Harry and Megan
they loved their family but given the
relentless media scrutiny the couple did
what they thought was right
for their immediate family and their son
Archie that said the source tells ET
that William wasn't happy that things
weren't handled privately
Megan and Harry made a final string of
royal appearances earlier this month
before returning to Vancouver Island to
be with baby Archie we all take your
leap of faith
so thank you for giving me the courage
to take this next step
[Music]